so washington now and lawmakers are  still working today on a coronavirus  relief package  president-elect joe biden is throwing  his support behind a compromise proposal  now in congress  this one would spend nearly a trillion  dollars to help businesses feeling the  strain of the pandemic  dr anthony fauci says he is meeting with  members of biden's transition team later  today  they will discuss vaccines and the biden  administration's cobit response  the president-elect spoke with workers  impacted by the economic fallout  yesterday  it just hurts us when we hear people  that  don't have any issues politicians that  are doing just fine  when they say oh they they don't need  that extra money  they're just lazy we need relief now  so i've been urging our congressional  republicans to work on a bipartisan  emergency package  now treasury secretary steve mnuchin  says president trump supports a smaller  bill  that senate majority leader mitch  mcconnell has proposed